هذه النظره شبيهه بتلك التي راقب فيها
منزله يتكون فوق عائلته اثناء الزلزال
حينها خرج من مشفاه فرا ليصدم بهول المنظر
لم يكن يسمح الوقت حينها للطبيب عبد
الباسط خليل ان يهرع لانقاذ زوجته وطفلته
الوحيده فالمشفى بدا يمتلئ بالمصابين
وقتها اختار ان يكون الطبيب للزوج والاب
لشعور كتير صعب بس ننتقل الانسانيه هي
بتجبرك انه تساعد المصابين ولو كان زوجتك
وبنتك تحت الانقاذ بس ما بيطلع بايدك شيء
انت لن تسرق الكارثه عائله الطبيب فحسب
فمسقط راسه مدينه الاتارب شمال حلب كانت
احدى اكثر المدن المتضرره بالزلزال وخساره
مئات الارواح
ومع تجاوز عدد الضحايا في سوريا
3500 قتيل تنعكس صوره ما الت اليه الاوضاع
في المنطقه المنكوبه شمالي سوريا على
ملامح وجه الطبيب وصوته
الناس تعتبر ان الطبيب هو البطل في كل
مواقف وبينسوا انه هو انسان مثل مثله
وعنده عيله وعنده واطفال لم ينفي عبد
الباسط تعبه ومواجهه لكنه لم ينفي ايضا ان
الاطباء هنا قاوموا مشاعرهم رغم حجم
خسائرهم واصبحوا اليوم بحاجه لمن يداويهم